particularly acknowledgement to Peter
Sims my co-author on the book who I met
here just three years ago at a program
similar to this and then starting two
years ago we have worked together very
intensely on this project along with the
third colleague dynamite who is also
with us back here in the fifth row
fourth row and Diana and Peter and and I
interviewed 125 people a leaders and
created something like three thousand
pages of transcripts but I'm
particularly pleased to be at Stanford
today and have a chance to share with
you some of my thoughts on leadership
and my focus today will be on leadership
in the 21st century because I'm
convinced that we need new kinds of
leaders in this century and I hope you
will be those new kinds of leaders I was
a kid at the Kennedy era and many of us
were very idealistic we came out of
school and I think we kind of blew it
and I very disappointed in my generation
leaders not just the crooks they're
crooks in every generation I mean joe
nachio is on trial right now and the
jury's out and how that'll come out I
can never judge a court of law because
I'm not a lawyer even if I were it would
be smart enough not to judge it but
these are not the kind of leaders we
want and so I'm hoping you'll be that
different kind of leader when when you
had the opportunities hopefully earlier
in your career sooner rather than later
to be the kind of leaders we need to
build great companies and great
organizations in the 21st century
because if we don't I think we'll see a
real loss of of in the business
community
I left Medtronic as you heard turn to
CEO job over just actually six years now
time flies and when I was elected CEO I
said to the board of Medtronic that in
those days I felt CEOs were serving too
long today it's too short
and that I should not serve more than 10
years I had no contract I told him I
didn't want a contract and my commitment
was that I would have a successor it was
ready to go there's art Collins it was
done an excellent job for the last six
years and now he's preparing to turn
things already his successor I stayed
one year as chair of the board and went
off the board but in that time I took a
working sabbatical in Switzerland and
taught a couple institutions over there
the Swiss Federal
technique and in a day or imd the
business school and found I really love
teaching and particularly love teaching
MBAs and got great joy out of that and
also great learning it's one of my
colleagues said to me bill never set
foot in the classroom unless you
honestly want to learn from your
students and so we've adopted very much
the idea that that you can't teach
leadership but you can certainly learn
leadership and in a classroom here at
Stanford or at Harvard
it's not about at least in leadership in
my classroom it's it's not about
knowledge transfer me transferring
knowledge to you but knowledge exchange
and that's the principle we've tried to
operate on I can say that I could not
have written this book had it not been
for my students at Harvard who gave me
such great insights and what they were
thinking and and became very very
important but why is this important it's
important because because of the actions
in the late 90s and all the egregious
cases in this first last five years
since the fall of Enron we have breached
the trust of people and business leaders
today the Gallup polls show that
business leaders are right near the
bottom of the list in trust only 22% of
the American people say they trust
business executives that's not just a
problem that's a formula for disaster
because when we live in a democracy most
of you who are Americans tend to think
of capitalism as a right I'm a fervent
capitalism I believe it's the world's
greatest economic system and it's had an
enormous impact around the world but we
will lose those rights it is not a right
it is a responsibility and if we don't
honor our responsibility society we will
lose those rights Milton Friedman was
absolutely wrong he may be a no Nobel
Prize winning economist but he is wrong
when he says any business than any
businessperson who contributes to the
betterment of society to environmental
causes gives money from his corporate
charity or worries about affirmative
action is an unadulterated socialist
which he says and we debate in my
classroom he just flat-out wrong about
that that's not right we have an
obligation we are chartered by society I
was on the board of a French company boy
and night in the 1980s when Francois
meets our own the socialist defeat
started to stand for the presidency of
France and immediately they carried out
their election plays the company was
nationalized along with 12 other
companies we lost our rights
sarbanes-oxley is a mini version of that
if we don't get this whole thing on
exactly because people complain about
sarbanes-oxley but the reality of
sarbanes-oxley is that we brought it on
ourselves and the same thing with
rampant executive compensation right now
if boards of directors and compensation
committees don't get control over this
executive compensation and you probably
started at Atari the New York Times this
morning if we don't get back to a
pay-for-performance system if we
continue to pay people two hundred
million dollars for failing I'll tell
you we will have legislation and we will
have controls over what we do and we
won't like them and will complain about
them but we will have deserved it
because we did not do our jobs so what
do we how do we come out of this crisis
well we have to rebuild the trust
business is all about trust when you buy
a product or a physician buy implants
and Medtronic defibrillator here in the
Stanford campus he has he or she has no
idea where that product works it's it's
trust in the manufacturer when you work
for a company you trust the leaders to
do the right things when you invest in a
company I always consider when people
have bought a thousand shares of
Medtronic stock that was an alderman act
to trust in the leadership to give them
a fair return and I felt a heavy burden
from that but we also trust business do
the right thing by society we have to
create jobs we have to create products
of value and services a value and any
business that fails to do that will have
no long-term sustainable shareholder
value if you can't create products and
services that have sustainable value
your customers you'll be out of business
so the idea that we only focus on
shareholder values short term
shareholder value well actually in the
long run we'll destroy value and we also
have to be concerned about major
societal issues like health care like
education like poverty like the
environment and if we're not I think
there's a big price will pay so I feel
that leadership in this century must
change
why must have changed I think because
the nature people an organization has
changed look I grew up hate to admit it
how long ago I grew up but my father and
mother
through two world wars they lived
through the depression my father lost
his job in the depression he paid
somebody 50 bucks to get him help him
get a job people just wanted a job when
they came out to the war but you know we
had this idea follow the great person
over the hill the kind of military model
and many corporate leaders operated by
fear intimidation and we followed those
leaders over the hill well I can tell
you you are not going to follow that
leader over the hill
certainly not because you're you should
look at for leaders who can empower you
to lead and give you the opportunity to
lead like dick evasive it's Theo
wells-fargo said when he graduated from
here so when I came out I didn't want to
be consulting Besim Baker I just want to
go run some I didn't care how big it was
I just want to have the opportunity to
go run something you deserve those kind
of opportunity and everyone an
organization does today you know we went
through this era where we dichotomize
workers and managers and I think we
created a lot of problems that's why the
automobile industry has never overcome
that that's why they're in such deep
trouble at least the American automobile
industry the Japanese and German
American automobile industry that
operates the United States is not in
that kind of difficulty because they
don't have that dichotomy and then
finally in the last twenty years of the
20th century we looked for the
charismatic see CEO the person who could
save the company and this this led to a
lot of the difficulties look if you want
to be charismatic don't go into business
you should go into the media you know be
an athlete you know be a musician be
charismatic become orchestra conductor
but charisma is not what's called
foreign business what's called for in
business is character business is not
about finding leaders with great style
it's about finding leaders with great
substance nor is it about finding people
with a great image a lot of people said
can you recommend a CEO has the right
image for Wall Street I said no because
I don't think that's the kind of leaders
you want an organization I think you
want leaders with integrity you want
people with substance and you want
people with character but here's why I
think if you're going to be successful
in this century that companies and
leaders must change first of all the
apprentice system is virtually
disappeared you no longer learn how to
do something from somebody's been doing
it for 25 30 years right now the workers
know more than their bosses do about
their jobs I never had a job where I
knew as much as the people working for
me
and you know so then you have to figure
out how can you motivate people give
them the freedom and bring them together
as a team and and enable them to do
their very best work
second of all whether you're whether
you're a minimum wage employee working
at McDonald's or whether you're an
engineer that has great opportunities
you know people today are looking for
meaning and significance from their work
sometimes we lose sight of that when you
get too close to Wall Street fortunately
here were 3,000 miles away because we
start to think it's all about profits
off other people's money but people in
organizations are looking for meaning
and significance and if organizations
fail to give them that they will not
provide three great organizations Howard
Schultz who founded Starbucks
understands that McDonald's went through
a period where they didn't understand
that they're coming back now so that's
the second reason the third reason is is
that people are not willing to stand in
line for 10 to 20 years they get their
opportunity to lead nor should they the
best time learned to lead is right now
look at Wendy Kopp whom we interviewed
for our book you know Wendy at 21 years
old founded Teach for America
she had no management experience no
leadership experience she encountered
great difficulties after five years she
almost had to give it up because she was
a million or two million in debt and
everything was declining yet she had
that impersonal internal fortitude to
stay with it and can make it successful
today 16 years later its enormous ly
successful it's one of the most
successful nonprofit programs in the
last 25 years and she's learned
leadership on the job but she had a
passion for making a difference in
education and providing a good education
for everyone can she change the world
well not all at once but one step at a
time and I think that's the kind of
thing she's doing so I am very much an
advocate for a new kind of leader what
kind of leader is that well it's an
authentic leader that's a leader that is
genuine and true to who they are it's
not a leader tries to emulate someone
else
Kevin Shearer who is CEO of Amgen said
he worked for Jack Welch back in the mid
80s and he said it well at GE there was
a thousand people trying to emulate Jack
Welch said it was bad enough working for
Jack but to having to deal with a
thousand people trying to be like Jack
was really impossible
but then he very thoughtfully went on to
say leadership has many voices you need
to be who you are because no one no one
can be successful trying to emulate
someone else so if somebody in your
company tries to remake you into that
leader they want you to become to fit
you tightly within the bounds of a big
company resist it because when you get
too tightly bound
you know you'll change and you'll be
different than who you are and you won't
be nearly as effective your good
qualities won't come out in the way they
could and yeah maybe Oh modulates or
negative qualities but if you look at
the great leaders are two to three
standard deviations outside the
company's norms and I think that's
healthy we need to let people be
empowered to be themselves and be who
they are let me talk a little bit about
the study we did we went out and
interviewed 125 people this is not an
unbiased sample we did not look at bad
leaders we picked out people that we
thought were both authentic leaders and
successful and then we came back and
assess each of them on their
authenticity afterwards we did not try
to make any correlation between their
traits characteristics and styles
although many my colleagues suggested we
do that but one reason we didn't is they
didn't say much about that in fact so my
colleagues at Harvard said will you
hopefully can you find out what those
traits are and it's just did not you
know that's not what matters well what
does matter what did we learn from the
study we studied 15 people minimum per
decade from the 20s up through the 70s
28% women 8% American minorities 12%
international people quite a diverse
sample of people we want to look at the
whole span of leadership across a
lifetime and we learned a great deal
from our study about leadership and
about how people think about leadership
today but the thing that stood out was
people the passion they found in their
life stories I never forget my colleague
Nick cavasso vich the old Wells Fargo I
don't dick we've been the target board
for a dozen years no I mean before that
probably the arguably the most
successful commercial banker in America
for the last 20 years and so I said Nick
how have you made what how what made you
that such a successful leader of Wells
Fargo he said I want to talk about what
it was like to grow up in
Washington in a town where no one ever
went to college we're the people we
honored there were no business people so
people he honored work we looked up to
her teachers and they were coaches he
said I learned no offense to Stanford
business that I learned more about
leadership on the athletic field in the
corner grocery store than I did in
business school why well he was an
all-state quarterback and every day from
as a kid from age 11 till age 18 he
played sports from 2:30 to 5:30 then
he'd run home grab a sandwich and go to
work for three hours from 6:00 to 9:00
because he was trying to earn money go
to college he had no money and this is
this was his ticket if you will so to
speak into college Dick said you know as
a quarterback I learned very quickly if
you had a team of 11 quarterback she
would lose every single game we had to
have outstanding people at every
position and I've tried to take that in
to Wells Fargo his words I and have that
so that every person in my organization
yet higher levels is better than I am at
their jobs and that's the only reason
we've been able to be successful the
peghead of mortgage banking I could
never do his job and the head of
consumer bank I never could do her job
and so we've been able to build that
strong team in the corner grocery store
I try to replicate Wells Fargo much
around that corner go show your friendly
local bank in every city in the West
every town in the West and every and the
Midwest as well so you see him taking
from that Howard Schultz has a different
story he grew up in the projects
Bayview housing projects in Brooklyn
drug-infested crime-ridden area wasn't
safe to be around he met he tells his
story he came home when his father was 7
and he finds his father sitting on the
couch and a body cast he'd lost his job
he had a great job his job is pick up
dirty diapers and deliver them to a
central point he'd slipped on the ice
broken is like he lost that day his job
his pension is health care
his mother was seven months pregnant
couldn't go to work they had no money
and his job as a little boy was to fend
off the bill collectors very very tough
thing well he saw his father lose 30
jobs he thought his father was a failure
he just want to get away from his father
and they argued all the time the day his
father died he rethought that and he had
a
different understand he saw his father
never had a shot and he said you know I
want to create a company that my father
would be proud to work yet that's why
Starbucks in 1986 became the first
American company to give healthcare
benefits to all its workers including
part-time today health care costs more
than coffee at Starbucks but he's going
to be true to that because that's a
basic principle on which he feels he's
building the company not paying minimum
wage but trying to create a good
environment between employees and
customers and to creat that
constellation he visits two dozen
Starbucks stores a week to see does that
still exist you probably saw his letter
to Jim Donnell the CEO challenging his
Starbucks are we growing so fast that
we're losing that old original
coffeehouse and so Howard is staying
true to what he believes it comes out of
his life story and I think that becomes
very very telling in the people we talk
to Andrea John third-person Andrea is
CEO of Avon products today she comes out
of a Chinese American immigrant family
she very modest family were values were
everything were discipline was
everything she 31 she was executive vice
president Neiman Marcus at 35
she quit cold-turkey she was on her way
to be CEO she gave my classroom I said
why did you quit at 35 and she said
because I saw his gonna be CEO and I
just when the rest of my life making
luxury goods for the upper one-tenth of
one percent of the American women and so
nine months later she went to Avon she
actually got passed over for CEO few
years later and as one of her board
members said Andrea follow your compass
not your clock in other words stay in
the course of the direction you want to
go don't worry about getting there at a
particular time well the new CEO didn't
make it 20 months later he was out of a
job
Andrea had been passed over gets the job
what's the first thing she does she
changes the mission of the company from
cosmetics to the empowerment of women
said that's the business we're in and I
had a guy in my classroom would work
there and I said how is it for a guy to
work at she said it's great it's a
wonderful environment because they have
5.5 million people today they had 1.5 at
that time she's been left 5.5 million
Brazil they're now from zeroes
start in China to a 300,000 now and but
she has this great passion she if I
don't have passion for the work I can't
be an authentic leader many of the
leaders we talked to went through a
series of very difficult times in their
life crucibles this we call the moor in
Venice picked up that turn from Warren
when he wrote geeks and geezers and we
heard some very very moving
crucible stories from people these
became the time that transformative
experience a unique experience in their
lives when they really got what
leadership was all about that it wasn't
about them and getting you to follow me
as the leader but realizing it's all
about we if how do we create an
environment where we all have the chance
to flourish in my own life I've gone
through a series of crucibles in trying
to become a leader I'm the I'm the only
only child of older parents my father
felt he never realized his gifts to be a
leader and so he put that burden on me
so from age four or five I'm hearing son
don't be like your father you've got to
be different it's hard to be different
than your father when you're an only
child but that was the mission I had and
he thought I should be you know CEO of a
big company yeah not just CEO and CEO of
a big company even name the companies he
suggested since he called coca-cola
stocks in 1937 he liked me a CEO
coca-cola
or if that didn't work out I could be
CEO of Procter & Gamble or the third
company was IBM now turned I worked in
summer jobs all his company was a pretty
heavy trip and so I was resisting my
father but somehow they had been
internalized in my head and I never
could figure out why I wasn't getting
elected leaders are selected for
leadership roles as captain my tennis
team or other things in school and so I
ran for president senior class I lost
two to one so then I went away to
college 800 miles away and I ran
election and ran first stood for
election six more times
lost to all six times so now I'm over
seven it's pretty hard to be a leader if
no one wants to follow you all right
well finally some seniors in my school
at Georgia Tech took me inside so bill
is a reason why you're losing it's
you're not getting electives because you
have a lot of gifts but no one wants to
follow you because it's all about you
you're so busy and so ambitious you
don't have time for anyone and no one
wants to work
you know that was easy understand up
here it's very much harder to change my
behavior to change the way I interact it
but I asked people for help and I think
I generally learn more about leadership
in those college years than just about
any other time in my life so then I went
to Harvard Business School graduate 23 I
was working the defense department and
about six months after I got out of
Business School I got a phone call one
of those phone calls you never want to
hear my father was on the line saying
that my mother had died that morning of
a heart attack and I was closer to my
mother than anyone else in my life and
for me it was a real sense of
devastation and feeling alone some of
you may have had similar experiences but
it was it was time that caused me to
really go deep into what's life all
about and what oh you know we only have
one short time on earth what do we want
it to be and then I recovered and came
and fell in love got engaged and I got a
second phone call three weeks to the day
before I was be married my fiancee drop
dead of a malignant brain tumor and I
was just totally devastated
fortunately I had friends around me who
came around and were there to support me
through what a really dark times but it
caused me to go deep inside and say what
do I want out of my life
fortunately very fortunately a great
blessing I met my wife penny just a
month or so later and we've been
together ever since and there was a very
very difficult time and 20 years later
took me 20 years the last cruise boat
last last I can accounted a is I thought
I wasn't out to being CEO I thought it's
gonna be CEO of Honeywell and one day
and I was on that path and I was you
know it was it was a tough place a
little bit political one day I would I
was doing turnarounds and I've always
see myself as a growth manager and one
day I was driving home and I looked at
myself in the mirror it was a beautiful
day like today and finally for the first
time acknowledged I was miserable
I was totally unhappy I was not turned
on about how many most businesses I
finally recognized that the company was
changing me more than I was changing it
and I was becoming a different person
why because I was on an ego
trip to be CEO of a really big company I
want help me talk to my wife and asked
her what she saw it she I've been trying
to tell you out for a year you just
didn't want to listen she was right
so at tronic audacity asked to join the
company three times over ten years it
was a little company grown to a midsize
company and I turned them down just
about six months before because I think
Medtronic and my mind was too small for
my ego and I thought wow this image
ideal I'm gonna be head of a really big
company Medtronic was not that well when
I call bent Ronnie back and talked to
the company and thought about what it
really was for this wonderful mission I
learned from the founder of restoring
people to a full life and health I
realized this is where I should have
been all along and I'll never forget the
day I walked into Medtronic it felt like
I was for the first time it felt like it
was coming home coming home to a place
I'd never been before you ever been in
that place where you feel like hey I can
really be myself here this is the real
me I can be who I really am I don't have
to be some different I can contribute
here people appreciate me for who I am
and it was just a wonderful feeling and
it was a great blessing to have that
experience so through those crucibles I
think we find our purpose in life and
that's where I should have been all
along and fortunately Medtronic was able
to grow up into a pretty good-sized
company but that wasn't what it was all
about in fact I've always thought the
thing I'm proudest of in Medtronic is
that we went from restoring 300 thousand
people a year to new patients to full
active life to now about eight million
and I think of all the things it's not
this market cap or the earnings or the
revenues it's really captured in that in
that phrase so from that I think we
learned from a lot of our leaders that
your life story becomes very important
because it gives you your sense of true
north and I think all of us in this room
know what we really believe if we think
about it at a deep level but we're
worried that when we go off into the
business world we're gonna get pulled
away from that we're gonna be pressured
to do something different we're gonna be
forced to make the numbers one of people
in this earth and the study talked about
when you know he only been out of
business school for months and actually
called me and said he was ready to quit
so why you gonna quit you only been
there four months he said because my
boss is asking me move the numbers
around because we got a client
presentation
we want to impress him with how this
company hasn't he said I refuse to do
that
I said don't quit hang in there and but
don't go beyond your values but he had
that early values test he stayed true
but he was worried and he's gonna lose
his job and sometimes people do because
are you gonna be subjected to those
pressures yes well you get pulled off
course maybe yes maybe no but the
question is can you come back to your
true and north will you be seduced like
many CEOs have been seduced by great
wealth great accouterments great perks
company planes and all that to be
something different than who you are we
saw so many of my generation do that and
I just strongly urge you to to think
about how what is your TrueNorth and how
can you stay on that course well I think
it requires development you have to
develop yourself as a leader it's no
different than if you want to be a great
athlete and bike in the Tour de France
or go to the Masters or a great cellist
it plays at Carnegie Hall you may have
great gifts but you have to practice
every single day and leadership is the
same thing you don't become a leader at
age 40 or 50 when you get that big job
you have to start practicing right now
the sooner the better and here's some of
the things here's five things that the
leaders we talked to said they thought
were really important in developing
themselves and just as a side note in my
informal study of leaders who failed
everyone who I've seen fail has failed
to lead themselves wasn't they couldn't
lead other people they failed to lead
themselves so what does it mean to lead
yourself what are the things you have to
do I think the first is gaining a level
high level of self-awareness Pete Sims
came up with this survey that was done
from the members of the Advisory Board
here the alumni advisory board business
advisory board in which they said the
most important thing in business
leadership is self-awareness well it's
easy to say the Oracle Adelphi said
thousands of years ago know thyself well
how do you do that you can be
introspective I think the best way to
know yourself is through feedback Joel
Peterson said feedback there's a
professor who said feedback is a
breakfast of champions I think it's a
great phrase you know
the hardest thing we ought to do is how
do you see yourself as others see you we
all have blind spots and we don't we see
ourselves we want to be seen I've just
asked on a radio this morning what about
people under narcissistic yeah they look
in them they look in the mirror they
look in the water and see a reflection
of this beautiful person except that's
not how other people see you they see
the real you and one of the leaders of
mid-sized company Doug Baker tells the
story when he was 35 he thought he was
on track to be a great leader he just
come back from Germany took over a
subsidiary company that his company had
just acquired in North Carolina and he's
announced to everyone we're gonna go
through 360 feedback
we're bringing the center for creative
leadership to do that and I'm gonna be
the first one to go through so you get
to evaluate me then everyone so evaluate
you and so he was pretty cocky and he
got his feedback back and he said it was
like somebody flashed a mirror at me
when I was at my absolute worst it was
just horrifying what I saw they were
told me I was arrogant conceited pushing
my own agenda not interested in anyone
else so then I went off with executives
from eight other companies and we spent
a week together and I was a really nice
guy and I really listened to their
stories and was very empathetic and I
was the last one and they gave me
feedback on how they saw me they said
exactly the same thing my people did
that all these things and so I realized
I had to reform I had to change who I
want my leadership and so I went back
kind of like somebody coming out AAA and
I went back and said look here's here's
the feedback you gave me will you help
me takes a lot of courage for a leader
in a high-level position say will you
help it's pretty hard to turn down when
somebody said yeah will you give it to
me straight but there's nothing better
than honest feedback and there's nothing
worse than leaders that push away people
to get minus feedback or shoot the
messenger we're surrounded fellow
sycophants who just tell now great they
are there's a real danger the higher you
off you go on leaders have to have that
happen but I think early in your careers
it's really important to get that kind
of feedback because then you can that's
the first step and to having excellent
emotional intelligence and really seeing
yourself as others see you the second is
testing your values under pressure never
listen to a leader that tells you what
great values she has or he has or even
watch people's values whether things are
going really well it's easy to have good
and things are going well it's when
you're tested under pressure that you
find out what your values are because
that's when you're faced with
sacrificing giving up things you've done
to stay true to your values John
Huntsman today started in a very modest
rural family in Anna and Utah he he grew
up to be you know head of Huntsman
Chemical now Huntsman corporation very
successful business multibillion-dollar
business but when he was in his late 20s
in the white house of Richard Nixon he
worked for the chief of staff Bob
Haldeman he thought he was doing really
well
one day Haldeman Kosmas often they said
John we got a congressman out in
Southern California who's opposing the
president's initiatives here's what I
want you to do we need to embarrass this
guy to get him turned around take this
number call this plant manager and I
want you to put 12 illegal immigrants
illegal workers in this congressman's
plant and then we'll send federal agents
in and we'll catch him and cause him
some embarrassment
so Haldeman says you know sometimes we
act or excuse me Huntsman said sometimes
we act too quickly without thinking
about what we're doing so I called the
plant manager and I started giving these
instructions he said 15 minutes later my
inner moral compass made itself noticed
I realized this was absolutely wrong and
I said to him forget that I ever called
I'm not gonna play this game he said I
knew instantly that was the end of my
White House career because Bob Haldeman
loyalty was everything and I went back
to hauled him and told him I wasn't
gonna do that and with it I had to
resign because but at least I was true
to my values and years later when he was
facing bankruptcy he was indeed true to
his values and stayed true to his
integrity it was that early life
experience I think he was able to
project forward throughout his life the
third area of development is
understanding your motivations how do
you balance find a balance between the
extrinsic motivations money fame power
glory we all like that we all like
recognition of our peers we like good
grades we like good salary or salary
increases are like bonuses but that's
all you like you may wind up at 40 or 50
and fine you've got the pot of gold at
the end of the rainbow and it's Hollow
it's empty there's nothing there
and you say is that all there is but by
that time it may be too late to go back
and retry
what's important in life I guess it's
never too late but it's very difficult
you need to there's something wrong with
those think we need to balance those are
your intrinsic motivation I think the
time to think about that is now just
think about what do you want people to
say about you at your funeral what are
they going to say you know and what
really motivates you are you motivated
by helping other people are you
motivated by your own personal
development you're motivated by building
a great company be motivated by making a
difference in the world and as you think
about that you can get a balance in
those motivations and when you can put
that together with your capabilities
you've found your sweet spot
I was with Kevin chair yet actually a
nasty article in The Wall Street Journal
on Tuesday as with a Monday at new this
new this thing was coming he's CEO VAM
John and they're going through a rough
patch I said you know you go through
good patches and bad patch this kind of
way business is but Kevin when he left
GE blew out of there and went AMC I
think he was gonna become CEO overnight
and he was very arrogant and very
dictatorial and he got handed his head
and he said it was miserable and after
six months he realized he'd made a bad
decision so he called Jack Welch back
and said Jack I'm ready to come back to
GE and Jack said Kevin forget you ever
worked here and slam down the phone he
said at that moment I knew I was cast
adrift in a lifeboat and I had to make a
go of this big operating job he said I
spent the two most miserable years of my
life
because I normally hated my job and the
people I worked with but I also had to
confront myself but then he got the
opportunity got a Amgen came along great
opportunity for him and he realized how
the motivation of working for company
that could actually save lives he went
in he said I knew nothing about biology
he got a biologist to teach him biology
he he rode with salespeople he worked in
the labs and he really learned the
business he understood the CEO for seven
years he was unlike before he was very
patient and eventually when he was
selected CEO he met individually with
the top hundred and fifty people in the
company and said what Wendy would you
like to see me do a CEO what would you
not like to see me do what are their
inputs and ideas do you have and he took
this and it gave him a mandate to make
this into the world's very broadly based
leaving biotechnology company
but you see there he was able to balance
those motivations not give up his desire
for extrinsic things motivations but to
balance them out and define his sweet
spot the fourth area is building a
support team we all need that team
around you you need one person in your
life it starts with one person in life
with whom you can be gut-level honest
that you can be you can bear it all so
to speak that person for me is my wife
penny for you and I can she's always
there to kind of say hey bill is that
really the way you want to look to those
people today you know and she's always
there to be my greatest supporter when
things don't go well and to kind of
bring me in line but things are going
well seemingly going well but I also
have a men's support group and I've met
with these guys for every Wednesday
morning for the last 30 years when I'm
in town sometimes I've been out of town
but and it's so great because a number
of years ago 10 11 years to be precise
my wife was diagnosed with breast cancer
she was scared I was scared I wasn't but
that wasn't scared about the procedure
or the chemotherapy I was scared she's
gonna die and I was scared of that too I
could sit down with these guys and have
a really honest discussion and feel that
level of support one of the people on
our study Dave Cox who's now living out
here the CEO calls media he said he got
fired from a job he said you know you
find out very quickly when you lose your
job or do you lose your family who your
real friends are and you guys may think
now I've got tons of friends well you
find out when things go wrong you find
out you have very few people you can
really count on that you know will be
there for you too thick or thin and I
think you need to build that support
team now these shared life histories are
invaluable when you hit the rough stuff
people really know you and they can
really help you and you'll be there for
them and it's it's it's a and so I think
having a support team is extremely
important the fifth thing is leaving an
integrated life the the people and my
students at Harvard number one question
they asked and thanked I spent about two
to three hours a day talking with
students in my office not about the
course but about the answer of the
question can I have a successful career
or a successful work and home life
many of them saw their parents and their
parents generation sacrificing their
families for the job and they know in
their early jobs before they go to
business school and I'm sure many who
have had this experience your employer
will extract every hour you'll give them
I was with a member of our extended
family the other day
and he was working a hundred and twenty
hours a week he knows it's not
sustainable I know but you can't have a
life you can't sustain that but I think
it's really important to think now about
what kind of life do you want to have
and put boundaries around your work put
boundaries are on you know think about
how much time you want to devote to
yourself to your family and your
community to getting out engaged in your
community if you don't do that now
you're liable to get yourself in a
pattern where you can't pull back
because you like you like what comes
from that super long work week but then
you burn out at 40 and now you're going
to live till 95 what are you gonna do
for the next 55 years and it's important
to think about that now I coach soccer
for 13 years you soccer for my son's
teams was one of the greatest things
ever did people that was a little weird
relief meetings it at at 5:30 at night
hey that's just the way it is guys this
is important to me I'm not gonna leave
these people at the peel so I'm gonna be
there and I think it's important to put
those kind of boundaries around your
life sometimes it's hard with some of
these employers they'll extract so much
I think you still need to do that when
you do those five things I think you're
now prepared to go back to your life
story and say where are the passions I
find that give me the ability to lead
Andrea Jung said you know and that gives
your purpose or leadership and and
Andrea said you know if people can't see
that I have passion for this business I
can't be an authentic leader I can't be
an empowering leader for them so that's
what leads you to have the purpose of
your leadership and align people around
the common purpose and a common set of
values and when you do those things I
think then it's quite straightforward to
come and empowering leader I love the
example and mulcahey was just knowledge
by fortunate one of the Americas most
you know respected and Byard companies
and an was called the accidental CEO she
was passed over for the job for some guy
from IBM that came in from the outside
virtually destroyed the place she took
over the 18 billion in debt didn't know
anything about finance she had to get a
guy in the treasurer's
tutor her about finances she could stare
down the bankruptcy attorneys and the
bankers the next day but and she had one
thing going for she'd built 25 spent 25
years building relationship people in
Xerox and she too met with the top
hundred people the first to quit but the
other 92 when she asked and then there
are 98 said are you willing to stay with
me stay with us to restore Xerox to a
truly great company once again and they
made that commitment and stayed together
and they've now well on their way to
doing that they have averted bankruptcy
but they're well on their way but Ann
wasn't able to do that because she was
such an empowering leader she said to
the sales organization was totally
demoralized I'll go anywhere anytime to
save a Xerox customer and she did she
was out in the field she didn't spend
time with the security analyst she
didn't spend time you know spending all
her time with shareholders and bankers
she spent her time with people that
created the value the customers and the
employee and she's restored that company
you can be an empowering leader if you
just engage people and be out there in
the business and I think all of these
things come together to enable you to be
what we call a true north leader someone
that's true to herself or himself and
can follow what you really believe and
some I don't know how it is for you all
but I know some people are a little
fearful of failure I say there is no
greater opportunity than getting out
there and leaving because leading is the
most fulfilling thing you can do in your
professional life why is that because
you have the opportunity to come
together with a group of people and take
on a really great challenge to get
knocked down figure out what you're made
of take on great barriers overcome them
and come back from them and create an
organization that's really meaningful
tool to create to achieve goals to go
far beyond anything you thought you
could do Medtronic went far beyond
anything I ever had for it because
people were so great to work with in
going after these goals and that to me
was the most fulfilling thing that I've
ever found in my professional life and
you can find that fulfillment - of
staying true to who you are and working
with a group of people to
to do great things because never
underestimate as Margaret Mead said
never underestimate the power of a small
group of people to change the world in
fact it's the only thing that ever has
and I want to encourage all of you to be
that kind of authentic leader who can
change the world and make a difference
thank you very much